the jurgen experience
because i'm obsessed with david goggins
this is all your fault stay hard this is
what i do to my mother i'm like mom we
have to meditate i don't want to
meditate mom we're going to meditate and
then in her mind meditation is prayer
right because she's very catholic so you
sit and you pray and i'm like and i'll
get her to come and sit and then i put
on david goggins and he's like if
somebody tells you you can't do
something you tell them go [ __ ]
themselves and you do it and my mother
said jason turn this off this is awful
why does he have to curse you want me to
read you what david goggins sent me on
my birthday i'm obsessed with him he's
an awesome human i send it to my nephew
all the time and plays because i want
him to get like
he gets down on himself we always get
hard on ourselves
he's a he's an awesome human being he's
i mean he's not a lot of those i love
you there's not a lot of those out there
this day 54 years ago
you took your first breath
with taking that first breath it made
you eligible to die
i hope you're not enjoying your day by
sitting on the [ __ ] couch with your
feet up
hopefully out there somewhere suffering
talking to that inner [ __ ] see joe the
inner [ __ ] loves [ __ ]
birthdays why
[Laughter]
i'm so jealous
because it makes you an even bigger
[ __ ]
because we feel it's our special [ __ ]
day
so we could just chill the [ __ ] out
most people wake up to just exist on
this planet
so joe
if you haven't gotten the [ __ ] after it
yet maybe you should five exclamation
points i'm obsessed with him i love you
dude happy [ __ ] birthday
five ex commotion points gawkins out six
exclamation points
i love him he i i listen to his book
driving i go crazy i've listened to his
book like three four times
this is the greatest birthday messages
ever god really is that's [ __ ]
amazing but he's suffering he's like i
hope you're suffering is exactly right
because that's what we do like you took
your first breath to know that you could
take like something you're eligible to
die [ __ ]
the only proof of life is death so it's
so you gotta suffer yeah the people i
know the most miserable don't suffer on
purpose right and and that's like we
were talking about working out and [ __ ]
like that like i
have depression obviously i don't know
uh comics get it do you are you on that
do you get depressed no
see you're one of those that's amazing
yeah i don't i'm not i'm not depressed
because i forced myself into okay well
also i don't have the chemistry for it i
think i do i don't have like depression
in my family
but also i've been very physically
active since i was young and there were
studies that was done like we pulled it
up the other day the thing about the
difference between the effectiveness of
ssris versus the effectiveness of uh
like
regular rigorous exercise they're very
similar and and some studies they've
shown that
regular rigorous exercise is more
effective than ssris
i think it's variable right like
depending on how bad
your baseline biologically is different
than jamie's
it's different than mine everybody has a
different genetics yeah there's
different there's there's a different
baseline so it's like no one can ever
say the way you feel is the way they
feel because they have no [ __ ] eyes
exactly every part of the problem right
which is part of the problem when they
prescribe medication they don't know how
you feel yeah so they're trying to guess
they're like are you self-indulgent is
this guy a [ __ ] hypochondriac is this
guy really depressed like is he really
on the verge of suicide because there's
a chemical imbalance or maybe his girl
broke up with him and he's being a [ __ ]
like maybe he's just down and he's not
getting after it the way david maybe
he's just
lazy sitting around playing video games
all day drinking mountain dew and he
feels like [ __ ] maybe there's that
there's that when a person feels like
[ __ ] it's hard to know if you're just an
outside objective observer
it's hard to know why they're feeling
like [ __ ] 100 i can remember and i
always feel terrible for my nieces and
nephews because they have too much time
and they have too much space like
growing up in my mother's house there's
10 of us 12 of us whatever in a
three-bedroom row home two and a half
technically but
so explain a row home to people a row
home if you've seen rocky like the
houses are all connected basically
who doesn't watch rocky david goggins
huh anyway i watched it 45 times a day
rocky was soft round 11 [ __ ]
okay so like he breaks it down to the
round it's the best but anyway he um
so so my thing is like we were on top of
each other like i do a joke about being
in the room with my brothers there
really was seven of us sleeping in one
room it was me and all my brothers and
then my sisters were in the middle room
and my mom and dad were in the back room
until my dad left and then my little
sister went in there because she was
where's daddy anyway that's a whole sad
story but anyway so we were on top of
each other and i can remember days being
like sad and i'd be under the table like
crying holding my dog being like no one
loves me right i don't know why my
brothers be like get up get out right so
i would just go play softball or go swim
or whatever i was doing you know and so
i kept active then there was like an
adult time where when i got into my 20s
where i stopped doing that i wasn't
playing softball all the time and it
started getting worse like i was i would
immerse myself in work or little things
like that but i wasn't working out until
i started the wrestling and really
working out that [ __ ] helped
so much when i get down and i'm i i know
i joke about goggins but i'm serious
when he says get the [ __ ] up and get
after it
it's that little moment when you don't
want to go is the best you'll feel after
you go yeah people like him are fuel
there's this 100 like jocko jaco willink
cameron haynes david goggins
those people are fuel
you know what they they're they're
letting you know
then i i hope i'm like a bridge to fuel
because like i do what they do but i'm
not as savage as they are you do you do
it you are definitely more than a bridge
but yeah but but you know what i'm
saying i want to let everybody know that
like you're not fire you feel
all those same feelings that you feel
too yeah like even though i work out one
of the things that goggin said to me and
he goes don't think i don't want to
procrastinate he goes sometimes i see my
shoes them running shoes i stare at
those [ __ ] for a half hour
before i put them on same and every time
he says it i'm like i know because but i
always put them on but i always put them
on watch the entire episode for free
only on spotify